Fassungslose Gesichter in Rio de Janeiro.
Brasilianische Fußballfans können nicht
glauben, dass ihre Selecao aus der WM geflogen
ist.
Aus der Traum vom sechsten Titel.
Dabei hatten sie sich so danach gesehnt.
"Die Menschen in Brasilien machen zurzeit
schwere Zeiten durch.
Die Leute haben so sehr die Daumen gedrückt
und jetzt haben wir verloren.
Das wird eine schlimme Woche."
Absolut in Sambalaune zeigten sich dagegen
die belgischen Fans.
In Brüssel bejubelten Tausende bis spät
in den Abend den 2:1 Sieg ihrer Mannschaft.
Die bei einigen eher als WM-Geheimtipp gehandelten
"Roten Teufel" haben sich zu einem Favoriten
gemausert.
"Ich glaube ja fest daran, dass sie den Titel
gewinnen können, aber dafür müssen sie
Spiele wie das hier machen.
Sie haben das wahnsinnig gut gemacht, aber
es gab auch ein paar Spieler, die heute nicht
ganz auf der Höhe waren."
Ein Eigentor von Fernadinho hatte Belgien
in der ersten Viertelstunde in Führung gebracht.
Kevin de Bruyne schoss in der 31. Minute dann
das 2:0, mit dem Belgien in die zweite Halbzeit
zog.
Rund 20 Minuten vor Schluss wurde es im Stadion
von Kasan dann noch mal spannend.
Brasiliens Renato Augusto verkürzte auf 2:1,
aber alles Bibbern und Daumendrücken half
nichts.
Brasilien ist raus.
In ihrem ersten WM-Halbfinale seit 1986 treffen
die Belgier am Dienstag auf einen besonderen
Gegner und Nachbarn - Frankreich.